michelle bachelet's visit to china was
the first by un human rights
commissioner since 2005
and many saw it as a chance to assess
widespread allegations that beijing is
committing human rights abuses against
muslim uighurs in xinjiang but during a
press conference marking the end of her
six-day trip she said that wasn't her
goal
i should state from the outset what this
visit was and when it wasn't this
business was not an
investigation official visits by a high
commissioner are by their nature high
profile and simply not conducive to the
kind of detail methodology
methodological discrete work of an
investigative nature
instead bachelet says the visit was an
opportunity to engage with senior
chinese leaders
she spoke with president xi jinping by
video and met xinjiang officials in the
cities of kashgar and umuchi
bachelet says she urged them to review
counter-terrorism policies to ensure
they comply with international human
rights standards but added a tour of a
prison and former vocational educational
training center or vetc
failed to lead to any firm conclusions
i'm unable to assess the full scale of
the vtcs i raised with the government
the lack of independent judicial
oversight of the operation of the
program the reliance by law enforcement
officials on 15 indicators to determine
tendencies towards violent extremism
allegations of the use of force and ill
treatment institutions and reports of
unduly severe restrictions on legitimate
religious practices
due to coronavirus restrictions no
reporters were allowed to travel with
her
meetings outside her official itinerary
were limited
bachelet has been criticized for failing
to secure unfettered access to xinjiang
several governments and rights groups
say forced labor and detention
sterilization and torture have taken
place in the province treatment
amounting to genocide analysts say the
visit has placed a valuable spotlight on
the region but the credibility of the
commissioner and her office has been
called into question
there is a high cost to their
credibility
if a
strong
and detailed report doesn't emerge from
all of this
beijing has denied claims of
mistreatment against the muslim weaker
minority calling them the lie of the
century
katrina you al jazeera beijing